- So other than like work,
is there anything fun that you're doing
and are looking forward to, I
guess, doing after lockdown?
- I mean, yeah, I can't wait to, you know,
hang out with friends
and that kind of thing.
And I love...
My wife is one of the most
talented people I've ever met
and watching her perform live,
or, you know, watching her work,
she's a dancer and choreographer,
is just absolutely breathtaking.
And so I very much miss that
and, you know, I also Canadian,
so I love to go to hockey games. (laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh my God, that's so Canadian!
That's awesome. (laughs)
- So those are, you know,
those are, yeah, things I
look forward to and enjoy.
- So wait, you're married to a dancer.
I didn't know.
So, I mean, has this
upped your dance game?
Do you know some new moves?
- Well, I think what's
so incredible about Emma
is she, like, we've done videos,
she's included me in her work,
which is incredibly humbling,
and she's just so incredible
at choreographing for
non-dancers, you know?
So she makes me look like I can dance.
And she also, in the first
season of Umbrella Academy
choreographed this beautiful dance scene.
They're in the park with
all the beautiful lights.
This very like long dance
and, you know, and Tom hadn't
danced that much before,
and she's just so fun
and she's such a good,
she's just so good at
breaking all that down.
- Yeah, they make you
look good, man, I know.
I've had to do stuff I'm like, "Nah."